- All right. Good morning everyone,
and thanks for taking the time
to join our session today.
I am Scott Warren,
I run the America's Cloud
Center of Excellence
for Capgemini,
and I'm joined by Cedric Bordonne,
who is a global technology
leader with AWS.
And the project we're gonna
tell you about this morning,
you know, Cedric and I both worked on
and was jointly delivered for our customer
by Capgemini and AWS.
Sorry about the little
bit of the late start,
we had some minor technical difficulties,
but everything seems
to be working okay now.
So, a quick run through
of what we're gonna cover this morning,
our customer that we built this AI POC for
was called Fortive.
So we're gonna spend a
few minutes explaining
who Fortive is and what they do
'cause I think it's really important
to understand their business model,
to understand what we were
trying to do with this POC.
we're gonna do a deep dive
onto what we call Fort BRAIN.
that is the actual project that we built.
Talk a little bit about some
of the business outcomes
we wanted to see out of this.
Get into the AWS services and architecture
that we used to build this product.
Show you some real life footage
of the product in action,
and then kind of walk through
what's next for this project.
So, jumping in, who is Fortive?
So Fortive is a customer
of ours here at Capgemini.
They're an industrial technology company
headquartered in Everett, Washington.
They have 18,000 global employees
and operate in 50 countries.
So really big company with
a big global footprint.
And I think one of the key things here is
Fortive does have an innovation
hub, they call the Fort.
And that hub is where the idea
that you're gonna see today
was kind of incubated and creative.
For their main like lines
and areas of business,
Fortive really focuses
on workplace safety,
healthcare, environment safety,
you know, servicing, frontline workers,
scientists and patients
in those 50 countries
all across the world.
So really key to
understanding what we built
with this BRAIN project
is Fortive at the end of the
day is an operating company.
So they've got all these
different companies
that operate fairly
independently underneath Fortive,
and you'll hear us reference
these operating companies
throughout the project
as we go through today,
and we'll use the term
OpCo to talk about them.
But you can see that the
OpCos that Fortive runs today
are really broken into
three main categories,
intelligent operating solutions,
so think of facilities
and asset management,
you know, in office
buildings, construction sites,
detection and safety, anything
around operating real estate.
Precision technologies
is really focused on
electronic and test measurements.
There's one company here, Fluke,
that you may have heard of,
that is really the focus here,
and they work in the healthcare
and all these all different industries.
And then their final pillar
of OpCos that Fortive runs
is specific to healthcare solutions.
So think infection prevention.
So during COVID this
is a really big thing,
wearing your masks and
sanitizer and things like that.
Surgical asset management
kind of falling in line with what they do
with facilities management, but
specific to surgery centers.
And then end-to-end clinical
productivity solutions for,
again, healthcare facilities.
So as we go through
this, you'll kind of see
how all of these companies come together
within this AI POC that we
helped Fortive build out.
So talking about BRAIN,
so if we look across
all of these different operating companies
that Fortive operates,
they all have different types
in different data stores.
So think structured data,
you know, Postgres databases,
SQL databases, Oracle databases,
things like Snowflake
for data warehousing,
each different OpCo could have
all different kinds of structured data.
Same when we get to unstructured data,
so think of things like SharePoint, Jira,
any other kind of document storage.
And then the third type of
data in scope for this POC
was software engineering data.
So every one of the OpCos
that you saw on that previous slide
has their own IT department,
you know, they may be using GitHub,
they may be using an Atlassian product,
you know, different code repositories
across all of these different OpCos.
And so what Fortive wanted to do
with the first iteration of BRAIN was
give all of these different
operating companies a,
like seamless integrated platform
where they could build chatbots
for their end users, for
their non-technical staff,
for their software engineering staff.
But Fortive really wanted to do this
in a way that was completely structured,
secure, governed
properly, and standardized
across all of the different
operating companies.
So the key here is we didn't want OpCo one
going building one chatbot,
these guys building in another
platform, another platform,
they really wanted to bring
all of this into a centralized way
for all of the operating companies,
and so that is the idea
behind Fortive BRAIN.
There was a previous
iteration of the BRAIN product
and not on AWS,
but one of the big blockers there is,
is it was static versus dynamic.
So if you think of building a chatbot
against a structured database,
something like SQL Server or Postgres,
there's gonna be changes in that database,
not just day-to-day with the actual data,
but the structure of the database itself,
the table structure, the
schema, things like that.
So in the older versions
of the BRAIN product,
anytime a change was made to
the structure of that database
or the data source,
we'd have to go and
remap the whole schema,
train all the new data every
time a change was made.
So really building this new
next generation BRAIN on AWS
was completely focused on
how do we turn that dynamic.
So if a change is made
in that OpCo database,
the tool and the AWS platform
takes care of that on its own.
And the actual OpCo,
you know, building and
operating the chatbot
doesn't have to worry about that.
Really wanted to, again, standardize this,
so each of these different OpCos
has different IT departments,
different levels of expertise,
different skill sets,
so making this very user-friendly,
as much auto-generated code as possible
was really key to this project.
And we really wanted to make this
as close to a serverless
architecture as possible.
So, you know, scalable,
on-demand, cost effective
on how we built this on AWS.
So some of the challenges we face
as we started digging into this project
and how we would architect
it on the AWS platform,
you know, there wasn't
really a set standard
on how to implement this type of thing
across all of the
different OpCos on Fortive,
they worked in silos,
so we really had to build something,
again, that was easy to use
and these different
operators could come in
and build it on their own.
There was no common UI
for building any of this,
so that was a key to the
project is to build out a UI
where you could add new data sources
on the fly very quickly.
And then, like I mentioned earlier,
and one of the keys to this project is,
make it dynamic versus static.
So some of the project
requirements we dug into,
kind of like I mentioned,
so a centralized platform,
governance security baked in
so the different OpCos didn't
have to worry about it.
We needed specific training
for each of the OpCos data repositories,
and we had to segregate that data as well.
So, you know, company one's data
couldn't be accessed by company
two, so on and so forth.
We needed real-time or close
to real-time data access,
and, you know, everything as a service
or a standardized API economy.
So I think this diagram does a good job
of kind of showing conceptually
what the BRAIN product
is and how it works.
So on the left hand side are
actually where the chatbots
and the different operating
companies would sit.
So you can kind of see
the different applications
and where those could live,
so, you know, things
like Teams and Outlook.
And then more importantly
and what we focused on
for the first version
and the POC for this was
streaming through Streamlit or JavaScript
primarily into web applications.
But there is, you know,
plans to expand this
and have a lot more different consumers
where chatbots can sit.
On the right hand side is all
of the different types of data
that we eventually want
to build into this product
and platform.
And so you can see these data structures
sit within the OpCos IT's environments,
and it can be lots of different
things from unstructured,
you know, Jira S3 buckets,
SharePoint, Confluence,
to the structured data
where we're looking at,
you know, Amazon RDS, Oracle
databases, MySQL, Snowflake,
and then the software engineering data,
you know, GitLab, Bitbucket,
other Atlassian products.
So the key here is we have to
build this platform in a
way where it can ingest
any of these data sources
within the OpCos IT environment.
So we've really picked three to start
for the first version in the POC
that you'll see when we
dig into the architecture.
So for unstructured data,
we chose SharePoint,
for structured data we did Amazon RDS,
and for the software
engineering data we did GitLab
for the source control.
And then in the middle you can see
where the actual AWS
environment sits for this.
And so this is the Fortive
BRAIN that we built out
where the OpCo user can
input their data source
that ingests the data into our Bedrock,
trains against the data,
and then allows the end user
application to access that
via streaming.
So as we began to build
and architect this,
there was some business outcomes
we really wanted to focus on Fortive.
First I mentioned during the POC itself
was the web interface
with chat functionality.
So we wanted end users
within the operating company
to be able to interact with this data
via chatbot using natural language.
We really had to make this
scalable and performant.
So there couldn't be lag time
between accessing the data,
it couldn't take hours to ingest the data
into the AWS environment.
And really, I think like
a lot of folks here,
we had to prove that this all worked
to get investment and funding
and buy-in from executive leadership
to continue on with the
rest of this project.
So it was really important
to show quick wins,
how we can do this in a very
rapid and scalable manner,
give them that dynamic data
access that they wanted
to be able to, you know,
prove out to leadership
that we could move
forward with this project.
Some of the guiding principles
we used on this project
as we dug into development,
first and foremost,
everything needed to be
infrastructure as code.
So the primary method we
used for that was the AWS CDK
and Terraform for the infrastructure.
So we wanted no access
to the AWS consoles,
everything done
programmatically through code,
through deployment pipelines.
GitHub was our data
source, our code repository
for all of the project that we built out.
Data processing was done
using the AWS Glue service.
All of the knowledge base
creation for ingesting the data in
and running the learning was
Amazon Bedrock knowledge bases.
We did agentic
implementation using Bedrock
that you'll see a little
bit more in a few minutes.
There was some existing front end
for setting up new data sources
and building new chatbots,
but we pretty greatly enhanced that.
And we knew we needed basic
telemetry and UX metrics
using some of the existing Fortive systems
that existed out there already.
All right, so with that, I'm
going to hand it over to Cedric
who's gonna dive into how we
actually built this on AWS
and which services we used.
- Thank you Scott.
Hi everybody.
So before I dive into the architecture,
I just want to give two or three words
on what we set out for
this eight weeks POC.
So our first objective was
really to prove to Fortive
that we can interact with three
different data sources type,
so structured, unstructured
and repositories.
We had multiple requirements.
So the first requirement is
that we wanted a familiar WebUI
so that the Fortive users can
adopt the solution quickly.
The second requirements
was that we needed it to respond quickly.
When you are interacting with humans,
you need answers in
seconds, not in minutes.
We wanted to keep it very conversational
and not asking and coming
back a few minutes later,
as you can see in the
architecture in the center,
you don't see Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So this is not an architectural decision,
this is a delivery decision.
So AgentCore went to GA
at the very middle of the
development cycle of that POC.
So we decided to stick
to what we were building
and to move to AgentCore
in the future state.
So with AI moving so fast
and innovating at that pace,
we all should be ready to iterate.
We cannot change every time
so build something, finish it,
prove and iterate in the next version.
So that being said, at the left hand side
of the architecture, we
have the customer view.
So the customer view connects to WebUI,
the web application runs into a container
that is hosted on Fargate.
So we did the decision of going Fargate
to have the advantage of
containers, the flexibility,
without having to deal with
the underlying complexibility
of managing all the
container infrastructures.
It is published to the
end user using CloudFront
and the web application
firewall for the security
and the delivery content.
From a backend perspective,
we decided to use API gateway and Lambda.
So to orchestrate the different requests
and to add a bit of
context to those requests.
Lambda passed the request to a first agent
that is the SQL query agent,
and that agent is responsible
of the prompt pre-processing.
So this agent makes sense of the request,
it adds some meaning to it,
and is able to understand
to which data source he needs to tap in
to give an answer to the customer.
So once it decided to which
data source it need to tap,
it passed the request to a second agent
that is in the action group agent.
And those agents connect to
the different data sources.
As you can see, we have
data sources as GitHub
and PostgreSQL connected via an MCP server
and we have a SharePoint
connected directly to Bedrock
using a Bedrock knowledge base.
So the whole session is
about static to dynamic.
So what makes that solution
dynamic is really the MCP.
So MCP stands for Model Context Protocol,
and this is a standard for
connecting AI models to tools.
So it's not only about connecting
to a data source and
querying the data source,
it's also about interacting
with that data source.
So if you are a sales manager,
and if you want to know
the results of yesterday,
you don't want to to wait next week
for a knowledge base to be
updated, indexed and everything.
So with MCP, you are
targeting the live database
and you can retrieve
the live data directly.
So again, MCP is not only
about querying but it's also,
it gives a whole set of
tools so you can interact
with the external systems.
So you can, for instance, start a workflow
in an external tool,
you can commit in Git,
you can add a new role in PostgreSQL,
so it's not only about querying,
it's also about interacting
with the data source.
For SharePoint, we decided to go with
Amazon Bedrock knowledge base
because here we have a lots of documents
and there is no need
for it to be real-time.
So you want to have a quick answer
and to pass and to go through
unstructured data and documents,
we are using Amazon Bedrock knowledge base
together with OpenSearch Vector database
so that we can retrieve the data quickly
and keep it short for the answer.
And not only...
so for SharePoint there is
a knowledge base connector,
native connector,
but due to the time
constraint of this POC,
we decided to go with the
web crawler connector,
which make the trick for the
POC but in the next iteration
we are gonna go with the Amazon
SharePoint native connector.
Why did we do that choice?
Just because of a timeframe constraint.
We had no time to go through
all security requirements
and checks from the customer.
So what does it look like?
So as Scott mentioned,
Fortive has many companies,
every OpCo has its own IT,
every IT has its own maturity
on how to handle AWS
infrastructure AI solutions.
So we made it very simple for
them to add a new data source
and then to interact with a new chatbot.
So as you can see there
is a seven-step workflow
toward any new data sources
connecting to a new MCP.
Let's say you are the sales
manager I mentioned before
and you want to know the
sales report from yesterday.
So you just asked that simple
question to the chatbot,
the chatbot answer to you with the data,
it make an analysis of the data,
it give you a quick analysis,
and then it also gives you
the SQL query that it chooses
through the database to get the data back.
This is important because
it helps you also refine your prompt.
So if you want more
precise data using that,
you can refine your prompt
and you can ask a better
question to the chatbot
so that you are closer to
the answer you're expecting.
For GitHub, you are a software engineer
and you want to know how
your code repository looks.
So you can ask to list a code repository
and to give you some recommendation.
And the chatbot we've asked
will answer you with a branch,
the structure of the branch,
and if it looks good, if
you might change something,
if you need to change something,
if you need to add something
or to remove something.
SharePoint chatbot, here
it's all around the company.
If your HR, customer support,
you wanna know if you have a
question on a product manual,
a user manual product,
you can just ask the
question to the chatbot
and it'll not only give you
the link to the document,
but it'll also give you the real answer
that you are looking for
with the source it tapped in.
That being said, I hand
over back to Scott.
- Thank you.
Yeah, thank you Cedric.
So as you there we were
able to build out this POC
like Cedric mentioned
in about eight weeks,
where we had the three
different data source types,
the OpCos could go in and
add those data sources
through the UI that you saw.
So I think it's a pretty powerful thing
to be able to stand up this type of system
supporting lots of different companies
in an eight week timeframe.
So I think we hit all the targets
and achieved the goals we wanted there,
but if we look at kind of
what the next steps are
for this application and
how we wish to expand it,
first and foremost, that
diagram I showed you
a little bit earlier
with all of the different
data source types,
there was Oracle on there, and Jira,
and Confluence, and many other things,
so that's kind of the next step
is adding more and more data source types
that are standardized and used
by the different operating
companies that you saw.
And the MPC servers
that Cedric talked about
are gonna be key for that
in keeping this a dynamic
versus static type application.
The next thing we're gonna add is
really utilizing some of
the newer AWS services.
That's one of the tricky
things about doing applications
and pilots like these is,
you saw that during the development
of the eight weeks itself,
there was a new AWS service
AgentCore that was released
that would've made this
a little bit easier
and a little bit faster,
but at some point
we had to kind of stick
to our architecture,
and finish it, show the value.
But really implementing things
like AgentCore in the future
are gonna be key to
expanding this application,
making it more functional,
and providing more value
to Fortive down the road.
And then lastly, if anyone's
familiar with AWS Kiro,
this was actually announced back in July
during the development of this
and went just generally
available from AWS,
I think a couple weeks ago now.
And that's one thing we're
testing and planning for
on the next version of this product is,
how do we integrate Kiro into
build this even faster and
make it even easier to use.
So some things we've started testing
and are doing right now
is using Kiro in the end-to-end
development lifecycle.
So the first thing we can
do is create a sample DB
to help test this.
So, you know, a very
simple human language query
was sent to Kiro in this case
to create us a sample database with,
you know, users, products and orders.
So with that very simple knowledge query,
you can see that it creates the SQL
to actually build out this
database in a matter of seconds.
So now we don't have to go
and manually populate a
database for testing or use,
we can actually build this
out real-time with Kiro.
Next we can create the MCP servers
to actually query against that data
and load that data into Bedrock.
So you can see the very
simple query here too
is create an MCP server and tools
for connecting to the
database that we just created.
And so about two minutes,
Kiro generated the code,
executed it, and spun up
the MCP servers where,
I think, during our
development effort this was a,
you know, several week process to do this
and something like Kiro can take that down
to a matter of minutes.
So this is, again, in
a way we can show value
to our business stakeholders
and bring value into the
next phase of this product
where we can significantly
reduce the development time
using a tool like this.
Next thing we can use Kiro
to do is actually test
that the whole Fort
BRAIN product is working
as specified using MCP.
And so in this we just ask it, you know,
how many products do
I have in my database?
And this is gonna go out
and create all of the code
needed to send the natural language query
to Bedrock using the MCP servers
to show back that in this case
the test database that was
created with seven products.
So think of this as something
we can significantly use
to reduce testing time.
So rather than having somebody
from the QA team come in
and build manual test scripts
or build automated test scripts,
we can use Kiro in this example
to create all of the test code
and then build that into our deployment
and testing pipelines.
And then finally we can actually
expand upon that testing even further,
where in this case we
can actually give Kiro
a business question.
So in this test we asked
who are my best customers?
And it's actually gonna build
a fairly complex SQL query
in this scenario,
where we can look at multiple
fields within that database
that was created and see
that Alice in this case
spent the most money with us.
So we really wanted to highlight this as,
you know, a very new and
cool innovation from AWS
that just very, very recently
became available to everybody.
But you know, as you are building
these types of applications
that are pretty complex on AWS,
have lots of different services
and architectures in play,
you know, this is really gonna be
kind of a cornerstone of
the future of this product
and how we go and build
it out in the future.
And it can hopefully
provide us some real value
and speed to market
as we continue to
progress with the product.
With that, that kind of
covers Fortive and Fort BRAIN.
So we've left some time
for questions at the end,
so just go ahead and raise your hand
if anyone has a question.